it's a moment like you know i live for  i've  waited for this moment for like 17  months  finally i get to see my son  cobin  hi  you wanna hold your  [Music]  you need a second that's okay  who's that bubba  oh the boobies  mr boobies huh he says so welcome  welcome thanks so much  he's very nervous  you can give them hugs you don't have to  be  thank you so much thank you so much  so thanks so much  look bubba bubba look who's that can you  see papa  you see dada  oh my god you'll be shy  you can give them a hug together  [Music]  [Laughter]  who's that guy  oh  look he's looking at you  oh my god  who is that so cute he looks just like  you  huh  it's okay  do you need a second  who is that  getting to meet colin for the first time  i couldn't take it like he was just so  sweet like  i'm a dad today because of him like  it was just  a very beautiful moment  [Music]  you